an ontario superior court judge ordered
right-wing protesters to stop blocking a
vital bridge between canada and the
united states on friday truck drivers
and others clogging the ambassador
bridge over the past five days have
disrupted industrial supply chains on
both sides of the border forcing some
auto factories to close the bridge
carries one quarter of all trade between
the countries
earlier prime minister justin trudeau
gave a warning to the occupiers who have
been severely disrupting everyday life
in the canadian capital ottawa for two
weeks
it is time for these protesters to go
home it is time to recognize that this
protest this blockade is illegal
everything is on the table
because this unlawful activity has to
end trudeau spoke with u.s president joe
biden about the demonstrations and their
conservative american supporters
we discussed the american and indeed
global influences on the protest
we talked about the u.s based flooding
of the 911 phone lines in ottawa the
presence of u.s citizens in the
blockades
and the impact of foreign money to fund
this illegal activity
the occupiers who call themselves the
freedom convoy have been lavishly
praised and encouraged by personalities
on the right-leaning fox news channel
police officers moved among the trucks
and other vehicles snarling city streets
collecting license plate information
demonstrators heckled and jeered at them
the protests started among truck drivers
angered by a requirement they be
vaccinated against covet 19 when
crossing back and forth over the u.s
border but it has metastasized into a
general anti-government movement how to
end the convoy yeah you got to end the
mandates got to end the mandates and
personally i want trudeau and whoever is
pulling trudeau strings pulled dawn out
of canada i don't care what happens to
them but they got to be banished u.s
authorities are on guard against similar
protests in los angeles aimed at
disrupting this weekend's super bowl the
department of homeland security is
surging additional staff
to its incident command post their
strong cooperation with the california
highway patrol the los angeles police
department the anti-vaccine protesters
are certainly a minority in canada 88
percent of its citizens have received at
least one dose of the vaccine
rob reynolds al jazeera